i'd love to talk a little bit about the
idea of kind of following your passions
so when it comes to careers i feel like
this would have been a bit of a sign
wave in terms of like people's sort of
sentiment about this where i feel like
back in the day was very much like pick
the thing you're passionate about and
follow the passion and then
through the rise of like cal newport's
book so good they can't ignore you which
is all about basically oh the passion
thing is myth like my passion is to play
football but i'm not gonna make living
playing football realistically therefore
find something
and just become really good at it and
then you'll naturally become passionate
about the things that you're good at but
then there's then there's still some
people that are like oh but like you've
got to fundamentally have some level of
passion about it what's what's your take
on the whole like
finding out the thing you're passionate
about and making that the thing that you
do for work i feel like purpose has to
go through a process of creating and
distilling and experimenting i think
it's not about
you know there's lots of things that i'm
passionate about you know i love cooking
i love you know doing all these things
but can i see myself doing that day to
day you know yeah no but i think there's
a question of
there's lots of things that we are
tempted to try or that we're curious
about but we don't actually again give
ourselves permission to experiment it's
really like a scientific experiment
could i pick three things that i'm
curious about to see exactly what
spectrum of passion i sit on with this
thing so it might be that you're a
photographer
or
you're curious about architecture or
maybe you're curious about making in
shoes or or making clothes and so it's
about okay could i give myself a 90 day
sprint to really think about
interviewing somebody who is an
architect speaking to somebody who
curates an exhibitions or is a is a
photographer that teaches under 14s how
to use you know vintage cameras i think
if we don't really break down all of
those different avenues or spend some
time understanding it we can't then make
a critical decision about what it is
that you say you're passionate about
we can that we all have these things
that we'd love to do
but fundamentally when you get into the
nitty-gritty it might be that actually i
love photography but i don't really want
to take photos of people i probably want
to look at the technical side of you
know what is a great photo maybe i love
teaching and so perhaps i want to teach
about photography but i don't need to be
you know running my own shows or having
an exhibition somewhere yeah but you
won't know that until you try
and so i think
part of the purpose
journey is experimenting and distilling
and actually just you know what i
thought i really love this thing but i
bloody hate the people that it attracts
or it's going to be a lot of money and
maybe that's not where i want to spend
my funds or fundamentally i am actually
no good at this thing so i need to let
go of it yeah but i think we don't get
there i think we want to do this full
evolutionary like tomorrow i am going to
be a podcaster and you start to do it
and then you realize actually i don't
want to interview people like i kind of
want to do solo things like
yeah but you don't know until you try
yeah hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day